welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the marvel phase four timeline
just reshuffled again
delaying black widow's release in
theaters from november 2020 to may 7
2021 followed by shang chi in the legend
of the 10 rings from may to july
9 2021 and eternals pushed all the way
back from february to november 5th 2021.
yeah this sucks and if you're watching
from a country that's handling this
pandemic better
i guess i'm sorry that other people in
this country can't keep masks on long
enough so that we can reopen freaking
movie theaters we are all super eager to
see the black widow film and right now i
guess i feel a bit like a puppy lured
into a car with a wanavision trailer
chew toy
just to be driven to a black widow delay
that's clever bastards
but look the exact way the studio has
reorganized this tells us a lot about
their priorities in the marvel story
lines going forward
and what titles we're now more likely to
see before others so
despite every reason to feel despair i'm
doing it i'm giving you hope
don't because i promise you there is a
silver lining here
that's not true he's not allowed to talk
about that because once we were in the
dark but
now we know so much more about the
precise rollout for marvel's future
a future that does still exist i promise
you in the future that is blowing open
even
sooner and a lot cooler than i expected
it to okay while black widow eternals
and shang chi have all moved back
from what i can tell as of now the other
marvel phase four titles are staying put
forth in february 2022 doctor strange 2
in march 2022
black panther 2 could be delayed due to
the necessary rewrites but ant-man 3 and
captain marvel 2
seem to be staying put as well
spider-man 3 while part of the mcu
is technically a sony production and it
remains scheduled for december 17th
2021 morbius remains on schedule for
march 19th 2021 and venom 2 let every
carnage remains on schedule for june
25th 2021 so 2021 will be
a good time now back over at disney
pixar's soul remained scheduled for its
november 20th
2020 theatrical release date with disney
still currently weighing the option for
a digital release on disney plus which
begs the question why doesn't disney do
that for black widow
is disney overprotective of marvel nerds
while willing to let pixar fans
now well i hope not disney needs black
widow to make
as close to a billion dollars as it can
the
entire studio has structured itself
around these marvel movies being the
tentpole releases
that pay for future big titles they've
already sunk hundreds of millions of
dollars producing and marketing black
widow and if black widow bombs
or even underperforms by a couple
hundred million we might not get all
those other cool releases we're excited
about they would just
dust away from existence now sure let's
talk about mulan
because mulan had a digital release that
profited it sounds like at least 260
million dollars
pure profit for disney and i'm sure you
can imagine core marvel fans like us
easily spending 30 bucks to stream black
widow but we got to step back and
realize that the real prophet from these
films does not come from that opening
weekend core group of fans who are gonna
go see it anyway
this person comes from the more passive
general moviegoer who doesn't spend all
of his time on youtube
who maybe the second weekend or the
third weekend might finally bring his
kids to go see the movie after hearing a
good word of mouth from one of us
that's the couple extra hundred millions
of dollars that pays for the next movie
and you're just not gonna get that with
a digital release
folks disney plus isn't even available
in all the countries around the world so
since d-lane black widow seems designed
to protect the future of huge marvel
releases
let's talk about that future because we
just learned some key takeaways
first marvel delayed eternals from
february all the way to november but it
bumped up shang chi to that second phase
four movie slot in july
just pointing out how throughout all of
these reschedules marvel has never put
eternals in a summer release slot that
could tell us how the studio might see
the film as a world building reset that
fans could wait a bit longer for
but shang chi now looks more like a film
the studio is more confident in as a
summer crowd pleaser but the real shift
here comes in the new way marvel is
introducing this next phase of stories
because before the pandemic
the plan was to open phase four with
black widow in may 2020
followed by episodes of falcon winter
soldier on disney plus sometime in
august or september
actually i've always believed marvel's
original phase four plan was
to launch this new era with guardians of
the galaxy vol
3 a plan that had to be scrapped due to
that james gunn drama in 2018
also worth noting that marvel's latest
delays likely pushed back production on
guardians vol 3 even further
allowing gun to follow up suicide squad
for dc with that recently announced
spin-off peacemaker prequel series on
hbo max
looks awesome but now marvel's only 2020
release coming this december
the first official chapter of phase four
will be one division on disney plus
and that is a big deal i'm gonna explain
why but before we continue thanks to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
oh rainbows
every can of bang is 16 ounces that
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and has
zero calories yet it tastes great with
over 20 different flavors to choose from
and unicorns one of those great flavors
is
a rainbow unicorn if you've ever tasted
anything so good it feels like you're
riding a unicorn across a rainbow bridge
it
is this can and if it's one thing you're
feeling while you're writing a rainbow
it is alert that's where
bang comes in check out bang on
instagram you can get 25
off your order at bang energy.com when
you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best bang self thanks again
to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
get 25 off at
bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25
oh where do you think you're going
rainbow unicorn back into my mouth you
go
now black widow appears to be an
espionage thriller in the style of
captain america winter soldier
probably dealing less in magic or cosmic
forces
than just pure earth-bound spy action
conspiracy twists
maybe not a dawn of a new era but a
throwback reframing the history we
thought we knew
wanda vision meanwhile looks nutso no
one including myself can tell you
exactly what's going on with this
premise with 100 confidence
but it's gonna explore alternate
realities resurrected androids
dark magic agents of sword possibly
mutants
and young avengers and it centers around
a character confirmed to return
in the doctor strange sequel i believe
as that film's
badass villain so while maybe not the
intended introduction to marvel's next
phase
one division might be exactly the trippy
bonkers comic book narrative
to open audiences minds to the
possibilities of the vectors
upon which this universe can expand by
opening phase 4 with wand division
marvel gets to be
bold it gets to say that all of the next
stories coming up the pipeline a russian
spy thriller kung fu movie hidden world
romance sci-fi comedy
fantasy epic they are all set in the
context
of a reality that can be warped at any
time by
unknown magic from a dimension beyond
our perception or
our control what cooler way to restore
our sense of wonder after thanos's
defeat than a story that says
back up there is so much you don't know
it just feels like a more natural
jump forward into the unknown a leap of
faith as opposed to
a cool but reflective step backward in
black widow look pandemic or no pandemic
streaming series are the way forward
they're a smarter way to unfold a
serialized interconnected narrative
because that's how
comics work you take your time you
experiment you have fun with it
and marvel clearly gets this concept
with their disney plus series which they
are full steam ahead on final production
has resumed for the falcon winter
soldier
and for loki and they plan to commence
shooting on she-hulk
hawkeye miss marvel early next year and
reportedly writers on these shows are
sitting in on each other's rooms they
are building
out this universe together now there
have been some rumors
that the falcon winter soldier must
release after black widow maybe because
black widow might set up some plot
detail in the falcon winter soldier that
would spoil black widow if we saw falcon
winner soldier first
i don't think that's true because if it
were marvel would not be rushing that
casting crew to atlanta into prague to
wrap reshoots as quickly as possible as
they're currently doing they would take
their time with falcon winter soldier
knowing the series wouldn't release
until summer 2021 anyways
disney's priority is clearly to have as
much streaming content ready to release
throughout the first half of 2021 to
keep that subscriber growth on pace with
netflix and hbo max that is why falcon
winter soldier keeps flashing up and
disney plus coming soon promos
so don't be surprised if we get new
episodes for brock winter soldier
in february with loki episodes shortly
thereafter look look look i
am bummed that we have to wait even
longer for black widow i miss movies i
like sitting there picking a bunch of
crunches out of my folds
while people look down the road and be
like why is that guy sitting by himself
with a notepad oh is that idiot on
youtube who looks into things too much
and talks too loud
i love the cinema experience so much
that i drove three hours with my
girlfriend to see tenet and i gotta tell
ya
cinemas are not the relaxing
distraction-free escape that they used
to be
it is heartbreaking but attendees to
movie theaters right now
just tend to be the sort of people who
probably don't really care how their
behavior affects others
they're on their phones they're talking
they're lowering their mask and coughing
in your eyeball
i do not want to see black widow that
way but from the moment
we saw early footage for wandavision
that immediately jumped to the top of my
list for titles i am most looking
forward to
if i can just stay safely at home
watching new episodes of wandavision
falcon winter soldier
loki i do not mind waiting until it is
safer to see black widow in theaters to
help it make the big bucks to fund
future spectacles like the fantastic
four in avengers vs x-men we are in this
together folks and we're gonna get our
dream stories one day
discuss these theories with me on new
rockstar's official discord server by
becoming a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
hit that notification bell follow me on
instagram eavos follow new rockstars
thanks for watching
boom
[Music]
you